[Aplausos]
[Música]
eeuu tiene un problema las protestas por
la muerte de georg floyd son la gota que
ha colmado el vaso en este vídeo vamos a
dejar a un lado la cuestión racial y nos
vamos a centrar en un problema mucho más
concreto la brutalidad policial
[Música]
pensadlo bien cada año en eeuu mueren
más de 1000 personas a manos de la
policía por supuesto que este número es
mucho más alto en otros países por
ejemplo la policía venezolana mató a más
de 5.500 personas en el año 2018 pero
seamos honestos estas cosas pasan en
venezuela y no es sorpresa para nadie
sin embargo eeuu es la primera potencia
del mundo todo esto es peor si le
añadimos el hecho de que eeuu tiene las
mayores tasas de criminalidad del mundo
desarrollado en otras palabras que con
todos mis respectos la policía
estadounidense no hace bien su trabajo y
esto es un problema más serio de lo que
parece
[Música]
pensadlo bien el estado es una
institución que ofrece servicios a
cambio de dinero que pagamos en forma de
impuestos de todos los servicios el más
importante es la seguridad da igual si
hablamos de un país socialista
capitalista o de una monarquía absoluta
todos estamos de acuerdo en que la
principal función del estado es proveer
seguridad a los ciudadanos pues bien en
este sentido eeuu deja mucho muchísimo
que desear
[Música]
pensando por un momento cualquiera que
viva en europa puede pasear por la calle
sin tener miedo de los policías sin
embargo las tasas de criminalidad son
mucho más bajas en un país como españa o
república checa la tasa de homicidios es
de 0,60 homicidios por 100.000
habitantes en eeuu este número es de 495
ocho veces más alta bastaría con
solucionar este problema para esta vez
de verdad make américa great again y
hablamos de algo que le interesa tanto a
demócratas como a republicanos
[Música]
pero no sólo eso por sorprendente que
parezca se trata de un problema que
tiene solución
no hace falta innovar basta con copiar
lo que han hecho otros países y tenemos
un ejemplo que puede dar muchas ideas a
los políticos estadounidenses españa
sin amigos de visual política la policía
española tiene mucho que aportar al
mundo y ya sé que si veis este vídeo
desde españa puede que os sorprenda en
españa- no tenemos una muy buena idea de
nuestra policía básicamente si pensamos
en la policía estadounidense pensamos en
series como csi o películas como arma
letal cuando pensamos en la policía
española pensamos en películas como
torrente sin embargo pensadlo bien
españa tiene una de las tasas de
criminalidad más bajas del mundo y
cuánta gente diríais que murió a manos
de la policía el año pasado pero la
respuesta es cero patatero de hecho no
es la primera vez que la policía
española se utiliza como ejemplo en
otros países atentos
parte afganistán un nuevo contingente de
la guardia civil para entrenar a la
policía en herat kabul así que la
pregunta es cómo puede solucionar eeuu
su problema con la policía que puede
aportar españa a este debate hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el ejército de policías puede que os
sorprenda pero el 6% de la población
estadounidense son lo que llamamos
veteranos de guerra tal cual como lo oís
hablamos de gente que ha estado años
combatiendo en el frente y que al volver
a casa se encuentra con un montón de
problemas muchos de ellos sufren del
síndrome de estrés postraumático que es
una auténtica pesadilla de la que muchos
no pueden salir otros son incapaces de
encontrar un trabajo a fin de cuentas
las habilidades que han aprendido en el
frente tiene muy poca utilidad en la
vida civil y por cierto un saludo muy
fuerte a todos esos veteranos de guerra
que seguro que estarán viendo este vídeo
no sé si lo sabéis pero muchos soldados
del ejército de eeuu tienen el español
como lengua materna y probablemente
alguno de vosotros estará suscrito a
visual político así que un saludo muy
fuerte para todos vosotros es un hecho
eeuu tiene una deuda con sus veteranos y
en muchos casos no son capaces de
pagarla
[Música]
todo esto explica todos los programas
del gobierno para ayudar a integrar a
todos esos veteranos uno de ellos es la
policía tal cual como lo es desde hace
décadas todos los gobiernos tanto
locales como federales han priorizado a
los veteranos de guerra a la hora de
contratar a nuevos policías conclusión a
día de hoy uno de cada cinco oficiales
de policía en eeuu es un veterano de
guerra y diréis vale y dónde está el
problema a fin de cuentas un ex soldado
parece la persona más adecuada para re
convertirse en policía verdad sabe cómo
utilizar un arma como trabajar en equipo
y cómo lidiar con situaciones de mucha
tensión y si tenéis razón el problema
[Música]
el problema es que en eeuu hay más de 18
mil cuerpos de policía distintos y cada
uno es de un padre y una madre cada una
funciona de forma completamente
independiente todo esto se convierte en
un problema realmente serio cuando
hablamos de la guerra contra las drogas
veréis hasta los años 70 los criminales
a los que se enfrentaba la policía eran
pequeños ladrones armados con pistolas y
navajas pero todo esto cambió a partir
de los años 80 con la llegada de los
grandes carteles de narcos de repente
los criminales estaban usando armamento
de primera rifles de asalto metralletas
uzi y hasta lanzagranadas y todo esto
que significa pues significa que la
policía tenía que rearmarse para poder
hacer frente a toda esta nueva amenaza
pensando bien hasta ahora hemos hablado
de la cantidad de asesinatos perpetrados
a manos de la policía pero para ser
justos también deberíamos hablar de la
cantidad de policías asesinados en eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
solo entre el año 2000 y el año 2014 más
de 2400 policías murieron a manos de
unos delincuentes que cada vez están
mejor armados y mejor entrenados
pensando bien hablamos de un país donde
todos lo sabemos es increíblemente fácil
conseguir un arma de fuego si a esto le
sumamos la llegada de carteles
perfectamente organizados tenemos el
cóctel ideal para una sociedad ultra
violenta en circunstancias así es
necesario una policía que pueda estar a
la altura y esto es lo que explica que
en el año 1981 el congreso de eeuu
aprobara esta ley
la ley de cooperación entre el ejército
las fuerzas de orden público es una ley
federal aprobada en 1981 que permite que
las fuerzas armadas estadounidenses
cooperen con las fuerzas de orden
público domésticas y extranjeras en
otras palabras esta ley permitía que
todo el armamento del pentágono' que ya
no se usaba en las guerras se pudiera
reutilizar para la policía pensando bien
cada vez hay más veteranos de guerra
trabajando como policías y además
utilizan el mismo armamento que usaban
en el frente de guerra el problema pues
el problema es que las calles de bagdad
no tienen nada que ver con las calles de
kansas city un soldado en tiempos de
guerra necesita un entrenamiento
totalmente distinto que un policía en
tiempos de paz que tiene que trabajar
con sus propios convecinos y la pregunta
es hasta qué punto los policías
estadounidenses reciben el entrenamiento
que necesitan
[Música]
pues juzgar por vosotros mismos para ser
policía en texas necesitas pasar unos
cuatro meses en la academia de policía
para ser policía en finlandia necesitas
un máster de dos años en loro de
hablamos de tres años y en españa'
hablamos de entre nueve meses y un año
en otras palabras que durante las
últimas décadas casi todos esos 18.000
cuerpos de policía estadounidenses han
dado por hecho que todos los veteranos
de guerra estaban más que preparados
para ser policía con apenas unas pocas
semanas de clase y como os podéis
imaginar no es suficiente pero esperad
un momento porque esto no es todo si
pensabais que en este vídeo queremos
criticar al ejército estadounidense
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados en
realidad hay una diferencia muy grande
entre el ejército y la policía y la
diferencia es estar
personal militar de eeuu ha sido
condenado a prisión por crímenes por
valor de 50 millones de dólares ya lo sé
sé lo que me vais a decir a dónde
quieres llegar fonseca bueno pues por
extraño que parezca esta es una buena
noticia significa que existe justicia en
el ejército de eeuu dicho de otra forma
que quien la hace la paga y esto se
explica porque el ejército
estadounidense tiene una larga tradición
de respeto por las instituciones si un
soldado comete un delito nadie le va a
defender todo esto explica que los
soldados que torturaban a presos de
guerra en la prisión de abu ghraib
fueran juzgados inmediatamente y esto
solamente es un ejemplo y os
preguntaréis qué pasa en la policía
acaso no hay leyes que regulen a la
policía en eeuu
pues lo cierto es que podéis juzgar por
vosotros mismos
cuatro oficiales de policía de chicago
son despedidos tras cubrir a jason
bandai y este es sólo un ejemplo que
hemos podido conocer da igual el informe
que leáis nadie pone en duda que muchos
policías cubren a sus colegas sin
importar si hacen bien o si hacen mal su
trabajo apenas hay regulaciones para la
policía de hecho muchos de estos 18.000
cuerpos de policías se autorregulan no
están sujetos a ninguna ley ni estatal
ni regional ni federal y todo esto
explica que si en los últimos años la
policía estadounidense ha matado a más
de 7.600 ciudadanos solamente 48
policías han sido condenados el resto ni
siquiera han llegado a ir a juicio
ah
pero esto se explica por dos razones la
inmunidad cualitativa y los sindicatos
veréis a diferencia de los soldados los
policías en eeuu si pueden sindicarse y
los sindicatos policiales tienen un
poder enorme en este país principalmente
uno la orden fraternal de la policía
tienen a más de 340.000 miembros y son
un grupo de presión con muchísima
influencia en washington su influencia
explica noticias como esta
director de un grupo de policías obama
ha causado una guerra contra los
policías
exacto cada vez que un político ha
intentado reformar la policía en eeuu se
ha encontrado con la negativa de los
sindicatos policiales y todo esto
explica cosas como el asesinato de georg
floyd el policía que lo mató sabía que
era prácticamente imposible que fuera a
la cárcel por algo así a fin de cuentas
quién iba a juzgarle las doctrinas
judiciales están a su favor los demás
policías le van a defender y las
instituciones políticas no van a alzar
la voz por miedo a la presión sindical y
diréis pero y de verdad la casa blanca
no se atreve a regular la policía
solamente por miedo a los sindicatos
pues lo cierto es que ya han salido toda
clase de programas para intentar
solucionar este problema por ejemplo
durante la administración obama se
aprobó el llamado programa de innovación
policial y las intenciones eran
fantásticas entrenar a los policías para
que aprendieran a usar la fuerza física
de forma proporcional el problema pues
la ejecución al final todas estas buenas
intenciones se quedaron en atentos
visitas a museos de historia
afroamericana y jornadas de debate entre
policías para discutir los problemas de
la raza en eeuu en fin creo que ya os
podéis imaginar lo efectivos que han
podido llegar a ser estos programas y os
preguntaréis existe alguna forma de
mejorar la policía en eeuu pues lo
cierto es que sí y ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
lo que españa puede enseñar a eeuu a
estas alturas seguro que todos habréis
visto ya el vídeo del asesinato de
george floyd si no lo habéis visto lo
podéis encontrar en cualquier red social
aquí pues no lo vamos a poner por una
mera cuestión de respeto pero lo cierto
es que lo que hace el policía en ese
vídeo no es nada que no haga la policía
en ningún otro país se trata de lo que
se llama una montada policial es decir
el policía inmovilizan al criminal
colocando las rodillas sobre la espalda
pero el problema pues que como siempre
decimos en visual político el
está en los detalles el policía del
vídeo coloca las rodillas sobre el
cuello en lugar de sobre la espalda
además la montada policial es un
ejercicio que dura entre 1 y 2 minutos
es decir el tiempo esencial para poder
expulsar al sospechoso y llevártelo a la
comisaría es decir que en este caso
podemos decir claramente que el policía
que asesinó a georg floyd estaba
haciendo una práctica negligente así que
la pregunta es qué habría pasado si el
asesinato de georges floyd se hubiera
producido en españa en lugar de en los
eeuu pues bien en este caso el policía
tendría que redactar un informe muy
detallado de todo lo que habría pasado
[Música]
en caso de que el policía mintiera un
médico forense podría analizar el cuerpo
y descubrir porque ha muerto realmente
este informe sería suficiente para que
la familia de georg floyd denunciara al
policía español y lo más probable es que
ese policía terminará condenado a varios
años en prisión según el ordenamiento
jurídico español esto es un delito de
tortura esto no es una cosa que me haya
inventado lo cierto es que ya se han
dado casos muy parecidos atentos
'españa cuatro guardias civiles
condenados por torturar a miembros de la
banda terrorista eta' y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos fonseca esto es
mentira españa tiene un montón de
condenas del tribunal de derechos
humanos en estrasburgo por brutalidad
policial y si tenéis razón existen
muchísimos casos de brutalidad policial
en españa'
sin ir más lejos amnistía internacional
ha denunciado varias veces violaciones
de derechos humanos por ejemplo durante
las protestas de los independentistas
catalanes la pregunta es y qué pasa en
los demás países bueno pues lo cierto es
que españa no tiene más condenas que
otros países europeos como francia o
alemania en otras palabras que si en
todos los países hay malos policías pero
si comparamos españa con el resto del
mundo descubrimos una policía que no
destaca por ser especialmente violenta
[Música]
y todo esto es especialmente
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta la
historia de españa' para los que no lo
conozcáis os la cuento hasta el año 1975
españa sufrió una dictadura militar como
todos los dictadores militares el
general francisco franco no tenía ningún
miramiento con los derechos humanos
durante décadas los españoles sufrieron
unos niveles de represión policial
impensables en cualquier otro país
europeo pero todo esto cambió en el año
1986 año en el que se aprobó la
siguiente ley
[Música]
ley orgánica 2/1986 de 13 de marzo de
fuerzas y cuerpos de seguridad y en qué
consiste esta ley pues básicamente esta
normativa introdujo en toda españa' algo
nunca ha visto hasta entonces la
violencia gradual dicho de otra forma
todos entendemos que la policía necesita
utilizar la violencia en algún momento
porque los criminales pues no son gente
bondadosa que va con una guitarra
cantando el cumbayá en la mayor parte de
los casos no atienden a razones y para
eso hace falta a veces recurrir a la
violencia esto es un hecho ahora bien
hay violencia y violencia y así es como
nació el principio que guía la policía
española desde entonces oportunidad
congruencia y proporcionalidad y menor
lesividad posible es decir que un
policía español no puede golpearte a no
ser que haya indicios de que tú le
puedas golpear primero un policía
español no puede sacarte la pistola a no
ser de que haya indicios claros de que
tú también vas armado con un arma de
fuego o algo parecido
[Música]
concretamente existe un principio muy
específico que se llama el sistema de
intervención operativa consiste en lo
siguiente antes de utilizar la violencia
un policía primero tiene que darte un
aviso verbal decirte algo estilo por
favor salga del coche que tenemos que
registrarlo el siguiente nivel si las
cosas se ponen un poco más duras es la
lucha cuerpo a cuerpo es pues si el
sospechoso de turno tiene indicios de
estar armado el policía puede pasar al
siguiente nivel de violencia las
llamadas técnicas de percusión esto es
las porras las barras extensibles o los
está ser eléctricos finalmente como
último recurso el policía ya puede
utilizar el arma de fuego pues bien
todos estos principios se entrenan en la
academia de policía durante nueve meses
en este curso se dan cosas como defensa
personal y por ejemplo está montada
policial se practica durante muchísimas
veces y en distintos contextos pero la
cosa no termina aquí
e
por ejemplo dentro de la policía
española existe un cuerpo que se llama
la guardia civil pues bien la guardia
civil tiene su propio programa de
formación continua atentos
implantado el plan de intervención
operativa patio en la guardia civil este
programa patio consiste en una formación
continua para todos los guardias civiles
cada seis meses están obligados a hacer
un curso especial de dos días en estos
cursos se hacen ejercicios para mejorar
las técnicas policiales cosas como el
cacheo o la dichosa montada policial se
prueban durante horas una vez y otra vez
y otra vez con los compañeros como
podéis ver no tienen nada que ver con
esas visitas a los museos y esos debates
maravillosos que están haciendo en eeuu
para que os hagáis una idea la obsesión
con la formación policial en españa'
llega a extremos como éste
[Música]
interior dotará a policía y guardia
civil con casi 1200 pistolas eléctricas
para poder usar esas 1200 pistolas
eléctricas los llamados tasers los
policías están obligados a tomar un
curso de aplicación especial es decir
que hasta que no aprendan cómo usar el
nuevo arma no pueden utilizarla
[Música]
es más os voy a dar un detalle muy
curioso veréis en estos cursos donde se
enseña a manejar los pacers es muy
normal que los policías tengan que
probarlo en sus propias carnes
es decir que agarran a un policía entre
dos y le meten un disparo de taseer para
que vea lo que duele y ya se lo que
estaréis pensando muchos sobre todo los
que veis este vídeo desde eeuu pero de
verdad es posible importar estas
políticas a la policía estadounidense a
ver quién es el guapo que le dice a un
policía estadounidense que te vamos a
agarrar entre dos y te vamos a disparar
con un taxi
pues lo cierto es que hay una pequeña
complicación a diferencia de eeuu en
españa los sindicatos policiales tienen
muy poco poder de hecho algunos cuerpos
policiales como la guardia civil tienen
prohibido afiliarse a ningún sindicato y
todo esto es lo que ha permitido aplicar
todo este tipo de reformas sin casi
ningún problema es muy posible que en
eeuu sea mucho más complicado la ventaja
pues la ventaja es que eeuu está a las
puertas de unas elecciones y las
protestas por el asesinato de georg
floyd son una ventana de oportunidad muy
buena para poner este tema en el debate
político
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que eeuu puede reformar
su policía hasta qué punto los países
europeos pueden ser un modelo cómo
podría mejorar este país si pudiera
acabar con uno de sus peores problemas
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribimos a visual político y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo darle al like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]